I have to ask you about our late royal
princess Carrie Fisher who is just such
a funny person and who is so smart in
this business is there a piece of advice
that she bestowed on you given that this
was you know your first major major film
that you could carry carry with you yeah
I really think that I think that Carrie
is such an icon not just as someone who
played Princess Leia but someone who was
just groundbreaking in that she was okay
with being honest brutally so mmm-hmm
unapologetically so and I mean there are
definitely pieces of advice that she
gave me but I think the best advice that
she could give anyone is just leading by
example and the idea that if you if
you're kind of messy and if you're kind
of complicated hey guess what we all are
and it's okay to be that in a situation
where maybe maybe millions of people are
listening to what you have to say she
was so brave in that sense and that's
something I didn't truly understand
until I until I think maybe now I'm
still trying to understand it that it's
scary to be yourself when people when a
lot of people are watching right and she
was so fearless I truly think that she's
gonna be immortal for it
[Music]